[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir jacques chirac a
présidé la cérémonie commémorant le 53e
anniversaire de la rafle du vel d'hiv
pour la première fois le chef de l'état
a pris la parole pour reconnaître la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
la déportation des juifs et lancé un
appel à la vigilance contre toutes les
intolérances sur place nathalie saint
cricq
[Musique]
jour anniversaire de la rafle du vel
d'hiv les 16 et 17 juillet 1942 quelques
10000 hommes femmes et enfants juifs
pour arrêter par la police française
puis déporté la rafle avait pour nom de
code vent printanier et en ce jour de
commémoration jacques chirac est revenu
sans ambiguïté sur cette époque vichy où
je cite la france manquant à sa parole
livrer ses protégés à leurs bourreaux
ces heures noires souillent à jamais
notre histoire et sont une injure à
notre passé et à nos traditions
oui la folie criminelle de l'occupant a
été chacun le sait second départ des
français seconde et par l'état français
un rappel aussi celui d'une france
n'était pas évident qui résiste et se
battait contre le nazisme rappel des
heures noires du passé mais également
appelle à une vigilance elle bien
contemporaine fusée vide l'extrême
droite quant à nos pas ici même certains
groupuscules chattem publication
certains enseignements
certains partis politiques se révèle
porteur de manière plus ou moins
ouvertes d'une idéologie celle au pop
racistes antisémites alors cet esprit de
vigilance qui vous anime qui nous anime
doit se manifester avec la plus grande
force en la matière
rien n'est insignifiant rien n'est banal
rien n'est dit social les crimes
racistes la défense de thèses
révisionnistes les provocations en tout
genre de petites phrases en soi disant
bons mots puissants réalité au men show
enfin c'était la bosnie que le chef de
l'état pensait aujourd'hui tirait les
leçons de l'histoire at il conclu c'est
ne pas accepter aujourd'hui d'être les
témoins passifs ou les complices de
l'inacceptable
[Musique]